along the same lines talking about
education to kill a mockingbird To Kill
a Mockingbird by Harper Lee it's a real
American classic and maybe the main
character Atticus Finch is sort of the
original justice warrior in some sense
before the concept of a justice warrior
became so tainted with the ad homonyms
that we see now eighth grade English
classes in Biloxi Mississippi are they
had to remove to kill a mockingbird from
their curriculum parents and it's very
few parents I would I would add were
upset about the language in the book
yeah the n-word shows up in the book To
Kill a Mockingbird
and a couple of parents complained and
the book has been pulled from the
curriculum the son Harold in Mississippi
received an email from a reader who said
that the decision was made not before
the school year but actually in the
middle of the time during which To Kill
a Mockingbird was being read and they
were told that the students will not be
allowed to finish the reading of To Kill
a Mockingbird due to the use of the
n-word this is terrible the amount to be
learned from the book To Kill a
Mockingbird so drastically outweighs any
potential damage from the use of the
n-word the values of compassion the
value of kindness justice explanations
of inequality from this book would be so
beneficial to students but it has the
n-word so I guess it's out that this is
sort of the argument actually against
sex education from the right which is
pregnancy and STDs are bad and abortion
is bad comprehensive sex education helps
to prevent both but it requires talking
about the fact that people have sex so
it's out and we're basically throwing
the baby out with the bathwater and
there's an argument from some which is
that to kill a mockingbird should be
taught in school but that eighth grade
is too early to read it I could not
disagree with you more
eighth
Raiders usually start the year at age 13
and are 14 years old by the time that
eighth grade ends my little sister is 13
years old she and every single one of
her friends are more than ready to
handle some sporadic use of the n-word
and benefit from the really good lessons
in the book I actually remember being in
fourth grade and being read by our
teacher mrs. Tuohy the book roll of
thunder hear my cry fourth grade when
everyone is 8 to 9 years old it's a book
about racism it's a book about slavery
and the aftermath of slavery I believe
and takes place in Southern Mississippi
and it was such a fantastic reading
experience and yeah there were some
descriptions of the way that slaves were
treated in the United States there were
some relatively violent things everybody
was 8 or 9 years old and no one was
triggered and everybody got a lot out of
that lesson and III think that when we
start to do this type of thing and you
have the right accusing the left of the
safe spaces and the trigger warnings the
realities is you also have the right
enforcing their own version of the safe
space you're not preparing students for
the real world and I'm sort of dealing
with this right now in some of the work
I'm doing in education where you need to
be realistic about the fact that not
everything is nice not everything is
good 13 to 14 years old is more than
mature enough to handle to kill a
mockingbird and and my last thought
about this was what kind of
decision-making policy do these school
districts have or at least the Biloxi
Mississippi school district where if
just a couple of parents complain in the
middle of reading the book they pull it
how is that a rational sane and
productive way to make decisions about
policy when it comes to what students
should be reading if a parent or two can
completely upend what is being taught
everything is wrong about this and it
doesn't seem to be improving nationwide
and honestly I
I'm I don't say this sarcastically I'm
not saying this rhetorically if you
don't agree with me that a 13 or 14 year
old is more than ready to read To Kill a
Mockingbird despite it having a few
references to the n-word email me and
explain to me why I'm wrong why
shouldn't To Kill a Mockingbird be read
by 13 or 14 year old students and I'm
open to having my view changed if if you
email me and you make a compelling case
as to why the Kill a Mockingbird is not
okay for 13 to 14 year olds I will go
back on the program and I will tell you
you know what I've been convinced the
parent or parents were right I just
don't see it happening facebook.com
slash david pakman show give us a like
on facebook quick break back after this